That is still one thing that we don't know and it's about angles.
So we know about probably it is whatever you give me,
I can't tell you what is the probability that light gets reflected or refracted.
I know the problem is,
but I don't know about angles and what we need to know.
Just that light rays of light slow down.
They travel with the speed of light,
but they slow down as they enter immediately because there is a Adam's particles
in there and it's more difficult to get through.
So let's slow stuff.
The index of refraction tells you by exactly how much.
So the index of refraction of the medium is given by this fraction,
the speed of light in vacuum.
That will go over the speed of light in this media.
So,
uh,
this is how we can write it up.
Let's look at an example.
The index of refraction of class is 1.5 so we know exactly what the speed of
light inside glass is.
Well,
it's a 300 million meters per second in vacuum.
And what we know is this equation.
So this is the next of reflection.
So I can adjust,
reorder this pink and conclude that a light,
if it travels in vacuum 200,
300 million meters per second,
but in glass it moves is the third of its velocity and it's only 200 million
meters per second.
So let's,
that's a pretty easy calculation and it's pretty neat.
And another absolutely beautiful thing.
Hopefully you have studied the Maxwell equations and pointing vectors in
physics.
Uh,
light is ultimately a wave.
So here above and below you can see some wave behavior and the rig is
essentially the wave front of these waves.
So light can be imagined as race.
If you,
uh,
take into consideration that I would need to compute many of these wave fronts
in order to take account for the way behavior.
And don't look at the rent only.
Look at the blue.
Uh,
this is above,
this is a vacuum.
And below this could be for instance,
class.
And you can see that the waves slow down in this meeting.
And,
uh,
what this means,
if we go back to the definition of the way from Stern,
the red lines,
that they are essentially bending because the wave fronts are going to look like
this.
So it's,
it's very interesting because if you imagine light as a wave,
it only slows down.
But if you imagine life as a re then events,
it changes direction.
So,
uh,
I think that's absolutely beautiful.
And the question is,
uh,
why is the light refracting inwards?
Because what I would imagine is that it continues normally continue with its
way.
Uh,
this T.
Dot.
T equals p I because if we just continue its way and it doesn't continue it's
way,
but it the fence and the question is why.
And now we have cal academy time.
Raise your hand if you know Ken Academy.
Okay.
Awesome.
Well educated people.
So this is shamelessly stolen from cal academy because this is the best way to
describe how reflection works.
So basically,
uh,
you,
can you imagine that you have a large car and the air vacuum interface is now
road.
And what
I mean the road is the air and Matt is glass for instance.
And imagine as you are approaching this,
this boundary line between the two than the first wheel of the car.
Like the lower left on this image is entering the market but the other,
but on the other side,
the wheels are still on the road.
So therefore this wheel was slow down in the mud.
But this is still going as fast as it used to be.
So what will the car do if this happens?
It was starting to turn and you know exactly when it would turn because this is
going slowly,
this is going faster.
So therefore it would turn inwards.
So this is I think an amazing interpretation,
lockable thing.
It's easy to explain who the ways,
because we've been the ways to slow down in the direction.
Then we can see that the circles are good to be here.
And then if you go out to the [inaudible],
then we will go exactly like,
like in the previous figure.
That's,
that's another intuition that she's going to ask if this is actually physically
happens because I don't think so.
No,
this is intuition.
That's why it's a bit,
if it's a good receding and then the,
it's a nice,
this is strictly an indication.
Okay.
So if you would,
if you would start to model a raise of lights,
uh,
like trucks on going [inaudible] they're going to encounter problems.
This part of the wave hits the media first.
Pens by the entire weight gets rotated.
[inaudible]
no,
it,
the,
I attempt to give multiple ways to interpret things because,
you know,
different minds work differently,
son.
Graphical ways are working for different people better.
Okay.
So Status Law and uh,
we're almost done for today.
Style slaw tells cob and what angle refracted raised or can you continue their
path?
And this is given by this expression,
science of the angles,
uh,
against velocities against that recipe.
Reciprocity call of innocence of refraction.
Okay.
So let's do the air class example of the previous image.
Let's say our expectations before we go.
So I'm interested in the relation of Fida I versus the 30.
So,
uh,
I know these expressions exactly how much you feed in degrees C is 60.
Okay,
excellent.
How much speed decrease?
Yes.
It's,
it's something around 35.
Exactly.
Okay.
So the light is reflected in words,
therefore the fida t must be less than the fee.
So this must be,
yes,
yes.
Let's compute the equation and see if this works.
And if it doesn't work,
we're going to call out the physicists.
So let's just,
we are there some things and let's put there the indices of refractions,
uh,
and the incoming light angle that we know and just some very simple reordering.
We are almost there.
And if we actually compute the side of 60 degrees,
we get this.
Well,
this is all we can also,
uh,
carry out the division.
But at this point,
I'm not interested in the sign of the 30.
I'm interested in feedback tea.
So I would multiply both sides in vertical Asian by multiplying with the inverse
of the side.
So this data,
you should be,
uh,
the rx sign of this.
And if I compute everything back to the degrees,
then I will get this theater thing,
which is 34 point 75.
So we're sat,
the 35 was very close to the actual result.
But also not to forget that there's different kinds of glasses.
I mean,
uh,
there's,
there's multiple ways of creating and manufacturing glasses and they have
different diseases of reflection,
more or less the same,
but it's still different.
But we can see that this is,
this isn't in your really good agreement with what we see in your life.
Well,
what did we say?
Theda t should be less than DTI,
but 35 is definitely less than six days.
So again,
physics works and physicists are a smart people.
And,
uh,
Justin,
matter example,
if you think about the car example or whichever example you like better,
you mean,
uh,
hopefully immediately see that if we would be going with the Yellow Arrow,
this is going to bend inwards after going back from the water to the air.
Nah.
Whoa.
Hold it right there.
Uh,
what is happening?
I don't see any reflection whatsoever.
Right.
But it seems to me that if I go back at around how much is this in degrees
[inaudible]
that seems to decrease.
Exactly.
So something fishy happens that's 50 degrees.
Well,
I don't know what is happening.
I'll tell you the name and we are going to compute better.
This is possible or not.
Well,
if it's not possible that our math sucks.
So,
uh,
let's see.
So what we,
uh,
what we call this is total internal reflection.
There is a critical angle and after this critical angle,
there is no more a refraction.
There's only,
there is no more a refraction only reflection happens.
And there is many examples of that and there's many applications of that.
Uh,
this is one of the more beautiful examples.
So let's go get what's,
what's going on here.
And what I know is that I have the innocence of refractions.
I know,
I know this big,
this degree,
uh,
that we,
just dealt with and something interesting should happen here.
Uh,
and something interesting already happened.
So I just plugged in everything what I have seen on the savage and I get this
and this is awfully,
horribly,
terribly wrong.
Someone please help me out.
Why is that
okay?
Yes.
Fine.
Can't be bigger than one.
Exactly.
So the support of the sinus between one and minus one,
at least according to my experiences.
So it's saying that the side of an angle is more than one is mathematical enough
possible.
So it says that there is no such angle.
What will be the angle of refraction?
If I would use using 50 degrees,
then it says something that mathematically it doesn't make any sense.
So math actually suggests to you if you use the right numbers,
it suggests to you already that this total internal reflection would happen.
Uh,
let's try to compute the critical I book.
And this I just reordered things.
This is hopefully the critical angle that I will be trying to compete.
Well,
if I have this deeper,
I one,
this is a relatively small number.
Diary is going to be refraction.
There is this critical angle on the second figure at which I have this 90
degree,
uh,
refraction.
So it sat at the critical angle.
This thing is going to be 90 degrees and after that,
so this is smaller than this,
after this critical angle is only going to be reflection.
Now lets try to compute this a note,
a lotus that 90 degrees here.
So what I put here is this is what I'm interested in and this happens when this
refraction is at 90 degrees.
So I put to sign to degrees specifically and I want to know this feedback that's
going to be that.
That's going to be into a
critical angle.
What if I actually uh,
do the computation with the 90 degrees that I'm going to get one for the
science.
So this is n two over and long.
What?
I'm still not interested in the sign of this angle,
I'm interested in the handle.
So I have to invert the other side,
both sides of the equation.
And this is the definition of the critical angle.
And if you write it in Wikipedia critical,
again you are going to get the very same formula.
But the most interesting thing is that you can actually derive this yourself.
And this is not a huge deprivation.
This is very simple.
This is where this 90 degree refraction happens.
So what is our expectation for this critical angle?
Let's look at the reality again.
Watch.
So this is,
I'm just trying to hint without saying,
telling you the solution.
So let's try it without hints.
Uh,
what,
what could be the critical angle here?
Raise your hand if you know the answer.
Okay.
Sorry.
I will.
For pedagogical reason.
I'm going to ask someone who hasn't asked before that.
Let's see if it's correct.
I haven't asked you.
I asked you before.
Nothing.
Nothing important.
Okay.
You have an important question in smaller than 50 degrees.
Exactly.
So the usual answer I get is that 50 degrees,
because I see a totally internal reflection,
but total internal reflection means that after sun,
at some point after that is moving into the reflection.
So it doesn't mean that if it doesn't mean that this is at point,
because if I will be trying 60 degrees,
I will also see reflection.
But this doesn't mean that 60 degrees is the critical angle.
It's before that,
that sample.
Okay.
Well there's your answer to.
Was this your answer as well?
Just always thinking that if it's,
if it's critical,
then you,
for example,
is the 50th grouping also reflection and then of horizontal one.
Exactly.
Yes.
What you have seen on the figure.
So at the critical angle,
you'll see this
instead of this.
So this is over the critical level,
so it has to be less than 50 degrees,
less than six and 50 degrees.
Okay?
So this is very simple from here.
That's just substituting.
This is off the fraction.
41 point 81 wonderful physics works and we are still alive.
So that's basically it for today.
Uh,
we have used reality to be our judge.
We are not just writing formula on paper and then be happy about how much we can
understand or how much we can memorize all of them.
We put everything to use and you will see all of this in c plus plus code not so
long from now.
So that would be the introductory course and a see you next week.
Thank you.